Biden's document incident involves
records that were inadvertently
misplaced in a locked closet at his
former office and some in his garage at
home the White House has said as soon as
we figured that out we immediately
turned it over and have been cooperating
fully with the doj that is not what
Donald Trump did and much of what Trump
is charged with is in that aftermath
it's the cover-up for lack of a better
term Trump defied requests as I told you
made false statements as I told you told
aids to hide and obstruct as I told you
Biden's classified documents don't
involve a single allegation of lying or
a single allegation of obstruction of
justice why because Biden didn't do
those things he's been he has not been
accused of any wrongdoing or charged at
this time
Trump's indictment could result in
prison time we don't know yet but it
could